creo que ahora estamos listos para hacer
conversiones / coordenadas cartesianas y
polares y viceversa básicamente son dos
maneras de describir un punto en el
plano en coordenadas cartesianas la
coordenada horizontal nos dice que tan a
la derecha o izquierda se encuentra el
punto y la coordenada vertical nos
indica si se encuentra arriba o abajo en
coordenadas polares el ángulo te indica
en qué dirección caminar y el radio la r
la distancia que habrá que desplazarse
así que tenemos dos formas de
especificar un punto en el plano y para
algunas funciones será mejor hacerlo a
través de coordenadas polares y para
otro tipo de funciones será más claro
trabajar con coordenadas cartesianas
pero antes de seguir avanzando
hagamos un par de ejercicios de este
tema digamos que me dan las coordenadas
polares y veamos que sean las 4 150
grados y quiero convertir esto a
coordenadas cartesianas es decir de la
forma x
lo primero que podríamos hacer es tratar
de darnos una idea de dónde se encuentra
este punto
coordenadas cartesianas con cierta
facilidad lo hacemos y tendremos que
desarrollar estabilidad en coordenadas
polares lo primero que yo hago
intentemos dibujarlo cuando trabajo con
coordenadas polares me gusta primero
pensar en el ángulo así que son 150
grados y en que tengo 90 y hasta el cada
serían 180 así que 150 están 30 antes de
los 180 que estaría por aquí 150 grados
y normalmente me es más fácil pensar en
grados porque los usamos todos los días
en diferentes cosas con esto tenemos la
dirección ahora la pregunta es que tanto
te tienes que desplazar y si observamos
aquí nos dice que cuatro unidades
entonces ahora vamos a dibujarlo y a ver
voy a intentar poner es esta línea mejor
le cambió el color y
ahora veamos digamos que esto va a ser
1 2 3 y 4 4 unidades ya estamos en el 4
150 grados y lo convertiremos a
coordenadas cartesianas como una pareja
x coma y ya tenemos la intuición de más
o menos los valores de la coordenada
vertical y de la coordenada horizontal y
escribiremos a x como r
el coseno dt está recordando nuestras
identidades trigonométricas
y es igual a el seno de teta
así que x es igual a shrek o seno de
teta que lo vamos a pasar a las
coordenadas cartesianas y sería pues 34
y entonces es 4 coseno de 150 grados y
ss no detecta que sería 4 por el seno de
150 grados
y entonces ahora vamos a usar nuestra
calculadora vamos a escribir a ver
primero voy a borrar y ahora vamos a
buscar hasta el cuatro veces el coseno
de 150
y vamos a ver que obtenemos tenemos que
es el valor menos 3.46
y que será cuatro veces el seno de 150
grados a ver vamos a ver es el 4 por
seno de 150 y eso nos da igual a 2
perfecto entonces tenemos que las
coordenadas cartesianas de este punto
estarán en
y así que vamos aquí están menos uno
menos dos aquí estaría el menos 3.46 y
luego subimos dos unidades y llegamos al
punto lo que es congruente con nuestra
intuición ya vimos sería equivalente
moverse en coordenadas cartesianas o en
polares
es decir 'quiero en 150 grados y avanzó
cuatro unidades pero ahora vayamos más
adelante no nada más conversiones de
coordenadas cartesianas a polares y
viceversa ahora trabajaremos con
funciones y haremos estos cambios hice
una búsqueda de problemas y me encontré
con este en el cual nos piden convertir
a coordenadas polares x al cuadrado más
ye al cuadrado igual a 4
esta es la ecuación de un círculo y
cuando lo hayamos convertido a
coordenadas polares será más obvio
veamos con qué herramientas contamos por
un lado sabemos que x al cuadrado más ye
cuadrada es igual a r cuadrada el
teorema de pitágoras también sabemos que
la tangente de teta es el opuesto sobre
el adyacente o sea que es dividido entre
ubs no entre x claro y también sabemos
que es igual a r seno de teta y que x es
igual a r jose no detecta ya tenemos
toda la información necesaria si para
algún examen tuvieras que memorizar
fórmulas lo cual yo no lo recomiendo es
más importante saber encontrarlas y así
nunca las olvidadas estas son las cuatro
importantes
regresamos a convertir estas coordenadas
polares y tenemos que x cuadrada más de
cuadra desigualdad erre cuadrada por lo
que entonces r cuadrada será igual a 4 y
de ahí pues tenemos que r sería igual a
más o menos 2 lo cual podríamos decir
simplemente que r es igual a 2 y aquí
tenemos ya nuestra fórmula donde está el
círculo bueno pues tendremos que
interpretar esto lo que quiere decir y
vamos a dibujarlo es que tenemos un
radio constante de 2 es decir que no
importa la dirección para cualquier
ángulo el radio es constante y vale 2 o
sea que aquí vamos a poner el aquí está
el vamos a dibujar el 1 el 2 aquí está y
entonces independientemente del ángulo
que yo tenga siempre mi radio será igual
a 2
y aquí voy a poner el número 2 y si me
desplazo un poco más estará por acá
luego en otro ángulo estar aquí y puedo
ir completando poco a poco y voy
dibujando este es mi círculo recordemos
la definición del círculo que es un
radio constante en cualquier dirección
eso define un círculo así que es más
fácil de escribir un círculo en
coordenadas polares el radio es igual a
2 continuemos este voy a borrar primero
esto a ver es por un segundo éste
necesito espacio para hacer más
ejercicios y voy a borrar esto de aquí
esto que está acá y entonces el
siguiente problema que tenemos me dice
que x al cuadrado más cuadrada es igual
a 9 veces y entre x al cuadrado
y ahora vamos a hacer un mapeo de lo que
ya conocemos así que esto que está aquí
lo puedo escribir como r cuadrada es
igual a 9 veces y entre x se ve
sospechoso pero miren aquí está pues es
la tangente de theta así que puede
escribir 9 veces la tangente de theta al
cuadrado lo siguiente que podemos hacer
es tomar la raíz cuadrada en ambos lados
y así nos quedará que r es igual a bueno
más menos 3 veces la tangente de teta
esto va a ocurrir muy frecuente en
coordenadas polares y de hecho yo creo
que sería buen momento de ver qué es lo
que significa un radio negativo
veamos retomando el ejemplo anterior es
lo mismo tener un radio positivo o
negativo lo que te quiero dar es la
intuición de que es un radio negativo
así que si tengo un ángulo theta un
radio positivo va en esta dirección y un
radio negativo va en la dirección
contraria es caminar hacia la otra
dirección
este será más
r y este será menos r osea vas caminando
en la dirección contraria en el ejemplo
anterior teníamos el radio igual a 2 y
entonces a este ángulo corresponde un
radio de 2 positivo y en esta dirección
es un 2 negativo dependiendo del ángulo
en el que me esté desplazando regresando
a nuestro ejercicio pues entonces da lo
mismo tener más o menos 3 y vamos a
dejar que sea r igual a tres veces la
tangente de theta hagamos más ejercicios
y voy a borrar esto que tenemos aquí
para chispas se me acabó el tiempo nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo